Imagine that you are not watching
the microcosmos right now.
Instead, imagine you are living in the world as
it existed around one billion years ago,
and you are the ancestor of this red algae.
Inside of you lies the DNA that you have
painstakingly acquired from your ancestors.
It contains the instructions for everything from
the walls of your cellular
body to the components of your organelles.
That DNA has changed and accumulated through
randomness and selection over billions of years,
and you are the masterpiece
sculpted by that process.
Except you are about to lose
a quarter of your genes.
The history of red algae can be told
in part through what they have gained,
lost, and given away over billions of years.
It begins with a tale that is familiar
to many of us in the microcosmos.
A long, long, long time ago, a eukaryote consumed
a cyanobacterium, only to convert it into a
photosynthetic organelle called a plastid.
This process is known as endosymbiosis, and
the organisms descended from that eukaryote
are now known as the Archaeplastida,
which is made up of three groups.
Green algae and land plants are
considered one of those groups,
and then there’s the other group
of algae called the glaucophytes.
And then there are the red
algae, called rhodophyta.
Like their Archaeplastid counterparts,
red algae have chlorophyll.
But they also possess other pigments that help
with photosynthesis and also often turn them red.
Now when you hear the word
“algae,” your mind might
first conjure up images of
the greener Archaeplastids.
But red algae is actually
widespread and influential.
For starters, if you eat nori,
you are actually eating red algae.
And red algae’s impact goes far
beyond that. As we've just said,
red algae got their photosynthetic
plastids through endosymbiosis.
But they also essentially gave their
plastids to others through endosymbiosis.
Many organisms, like diatoms, can trace the
origins of their photosynthetic capabilities
to an ancestor that consumed and converted
a red algae plastid into its own machinery.
So red algae have a legacy that
spans far beyond their own actions.
They show up embedded in the ways
that other organisms are able to live,
in every bit of food they derive from the sun
and the chemical byproducts that sustain us all.
But for all that red algae were able to
gain and share through endosymbiosis,
their history is also marked
by the things they’ve lost.
Like their genes.
One of the things that is
really striking about red
algae is they don’t seem to have that
many genes compared to other eukaryotes.
And more weirdly, it seems like they
actually once did have more genes…
they just lost them.
It’s hard to pick apart exactly
how red algae lost their genes.
And we can’t say if it happened very suddenly,
or if it was more a gradual chipping
away at their genomes.
But based on the species
they’re able to study today,
scientists think there were at least
two major phases of genome reduction.
The first likely involved some old lineage of
red algae, which likely lost about 25% of their genes.
And in this process, they lost
a key feature: the flagellum,
that thread-like structure that many
eukaryotes use to drive themselves around.
And there are some interesting implications
to losing the flagellum, especially for
an aquatic organism like red algae that would
probably want to be able to swim to locations
that allow them better access to light,
or to find other algae to reproduce with.
But perhaps that ancestral red algae
was living in conditions where the
energy required to make flagella and
operate them just wasn't worth it.
Maybe it just thrived without the flagellum,
and there never was a reason to keep it.
In that case, that ancestral red algae’s
loss seems to have been justified.
Because red algae are thriving without
their flagella, and without any number
of other pathways that were lost with those genes.
And in fact, in the second phase, another red
algae would reduce its genome by another 25%.
The descendants of that algae became
members of a group known as Cyanidiophytina.
The algae within this group—
and particularly those from
the class Cyanidiophyceae—
are particularly well-studied
because they are extremophiles,
meaning they are found in environments
that are incredibly difficult to survive in.
Heat? Acid? Metal? Salt?
All things we might tolerate
in a very specific range,
but these red algae extremophiles are not phased.
Some can survive in acidic environments
whose pH values range from 0 to 4.
For context, the least painful end of that
scale would be like living in acid rain.
The most painful?
Like battery acid.
And as far as temperature goes,
there are species that can survive at 56
degrees Celsius, or 132 degrees Fahrenheit.
So the reason we’re not actually featuring any
Cyanidiophytes is that they tend to be
found in places like volcanos or hot springs.
No, our red algae are their tamer cousins,
found living along a Spanish beach.
But how could the Cyanidiophytes have
survived such extreme conditions when
they have lost so much of their genome?
Surely those lost genes were useful for something?
Maybe.
But it turns out the
cyanidiophytes had a back-up plan:
they could get the genes they
needed from their neighbors.
There’s a process scientists have
been unraveling over the past few
decades called horizontal gene transfer, where
genetic material gets moved from one species
to another.
And in general, we know it as a
process that happens in prokaryotes,
driven by viruses or other vectors that are able
to transfer DNA from one organism to another.
And prokaryotes are well-suited to not
only take in genetic material this way,
but also to quickly embed those changes in
their population as they divide asexually.
Eukaryotes seemed unlikely to
engage in horizontal gene transfer,
if only because we couldn’t
readily find examples of it.
But when scientists studied the
genome of Cyanidiophyceae algae,
they found hundreds of genes in them that seemed
to come from bacteria, and that seemed to help
with various functions like surviving
high temperatures or salty conditions.
And so the same group of organisms that
lost so much of itself also found a way
to gain so much of others, adopting the genes of
other organisms into their own way of life.
And the most exciting thing is how
much there is still to learn.
We still really don’t know that
much about how horizontal gene
transfer shows up in the history of eukaryotes.
We don’t know whether red algae have gone
through other major phases of genome reduction.
We know simply that nature’s boundaries are
porous, and its identities are multi-faceted.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people on your screen right now, they are
the people who allow us to spend so much time
gathering beautiful footage and also beautiful
and wonderful and bizarre stories of our world.
And then to combine them for you to look
at here on Journey to the Microcosmos.
If you would like to be one of those
people, there's a way to do that.
You just go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you'd like to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button, somewhere nearby.